Trascrizione: Isotta Rossoni
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Ma voi, da piccoli,
ce l'avevate quell'oggetto magico,
anche semplice,
che vi permetteva di volare
fuori dalla vostra cameretta,
e sognare?
Il mio era una piccola valigetta rossa.
All'età di quattro anni
avevo un bauletto rosso,
quello con i pulsanti a scatto.
Era un oggetto importante, per me,
e io ogni volta mettevo in scena
sempre la stessa storia:
chiudo il mio bauletto, clack,
e vado verso la porta
sognando di prendere un volo
e partire per un'avventura.
All'età di nove anni, avevo una valigia
un pochino più grande, ma sempre rossa.
Quella con cui, come tutti
i figli dei separati,
mi spostavo tra mamma, papà e i nonni
che nel mio caso vivevano
non soltanto in città diverse,
ma anche nazioni.
Accanto ai mal di pancia
tipici da distacco,
e l'emozione di vedere un genitore
piuttosto che un altro,
c'era una cosa che mi entusiasmava
veramente tanto, in quegli spostamenti:
il volo.
Finire con un portadocumenti al collo,
ed essere affidata a un'hostess di volo,
mi faceva vivere la magia di un'avventura.
E la sola idea di volare mi dava energia,
e aumentava in me il desiderio
di scoprire il mondo.
Con una motivazione così forte,
non stupisce che a soli vent'anni
indossassi una divisa, quella di Alitalia,
pronta per spiccare il mio volo.
Era ancora l'epoca in cui un aereo
destava fascino e ammirazione:
era l'unico mezzo di connessione
di luoghi lontani.
E io avevo realizzato
il mio sogno: il volo.
Volare appagava quel desiderio
di scoperta e di avventura
che era già iniziato
durante la mia infanzia,
quando i protagonisti eravamo io
e la mia valigia rossa.
Ma la vista privilegiata
sopra i cieli del mondo,
e la conquista delle mie ali
della libertà,
non mi hanno messa al riparo dalle cadute.
Quella caduta in cui ci si fa anche male
arriva all'improvviso, in silenzio,
senza che te l'aspetti.
La mia mi ha colto alla sprovvista,
è stata surreale.
Un po' come quel quadro di Salvador Dalì.
Non so se lo conoscete,
quello con il nome lunghissimo:
"Il sogno del volo dell'ape
intorno a una melagrana,
prima del risveglio.
Io l'ho scoperto da poco,
e mi ci sono subito ritrovata
perché parla del risveglio di una donna
dai suoi sogni tranquilli.
Il mio primo risveglio
dai sogni tranquilli
è arrivato a 27 anni,
quando dopo una gravidanza complicata
ho dato alla luce
il mio secondo figlio, Alessandro,
con quasi tre mesi di anticipo.
Rivedo ancora lo sguardo del medico,
mentre mi dice:
"Signora, le condizioni del bambino
sono molto gravi, si prepari al peggio."
Finisco in un buio insopportabile:
sento solo angoscia e impotenza.
Vedere mio figlio così piccino,
attaccato a tutte quelle macchine
è paralizzante,
e la sola idea di vivere
una vita senza di lui
mi fa desiderare di non esistere più.
Fino a quando un giorno,
improvvisamente,
scatta in me qualcosa
che mi ricollega alle mie ali,
che mi sollevano dal letto
e mi fanno guardare a quell'angoscia
in un modo nuovo.
Una forza che non pensavo di avere,
perché effettivamente forse resta nascosta
fino a quando non serve davvero.
Una forza che richiede
un coraggio particolare
che c'è, si trova in fondo al cuore;
e irrompe all'improvviso,
riempiendo tutto di energia vitale
che mi ha rimesso in movimento.
Immaginiamola come una formula magica
con questi elementi:
coraggio, cuore e azione.
Il mio coraggio di agire
l'ho trovato dopo sette giorni
in cui ero paralizzata a letto
dalla paura di perdere il mio bambino.
È scattato un qualche cosa
per cui, anziché subire passivamente,
ho deciso che avrei impiegato
tutte quante le mie forze
accanto a quel corpicino
attaccato a decine di tubi,
e sospeso tra la vita e la morte;
e che avrei lottato,
sarei stata accanto a lui
pronta ad accettare
qualunque cosa fosse accaduta.
In quella svolta c'è stata
una scelta consapevole,
quella di uscire
dalla paralisi del terrore,
smettere di sentirmi vittima degli eventi
e diventare protagonista.
Una scelta che ha cambiato tutto,
e che ha rimesso in moto l'energia,
grazie a coraggio, cuore e azione.
E da quel momento in poi, come per magia,
mio figlio è uscito fuori dal coma.
Un miracolo oltre i limiti
e le aspettative della medicina?
Forse.
Ma io sono profondamente cambiata,
e quel cambiamento ha spalancato la porta
al capitolo successivo della mia vita.
Così, lentamente, ho ripreso il mio volo.
E dopo quasi 20 anni di viaggi
e avventure intorno al pianeta,
ho deciso che era arrivato il momento
per togliere per sempre la divisa
e cambiare rotta alla mia vita.
Fino ad allora, credevo di aver vissuto
molte esperienze, superato diverse sfide.
Credevo anche che fosse il momento giusto
per compiere quella scelta,
vista anche la tormentata
storia di Alitalia;
e soprattutto anche per dare
più stabilità ai miei figli.
E poco dopo aver lasciato il mio lavoro,
in un momento di transizione
non semplice della mia vita,
è arrivato anche un momento
di gioia, nella mia vita,
con l'arrivo inaspettato
di un terzo figlio.
Ma quello che non sapevo
era che quella gioia
era l'attimo prima
di un altro violento risveglio
dai sogni tranquilli.
In un attimo, sono finita
in un tunnel buio
fatto di dolore, solitudine e delusione.
Dolore perché ero diventata il bersaglio
di continue umiliazioni e denigrazioni,
che quotidianamente
facevano a pezzi la mia dignità
Solitudine perché ho visto persone
prendere le distanze
da quello che stavo vivendo
e leggevo nei loro sguardi
un pensiero ricorrente
che semplifica tutto in un:
Vabbè dai, se ci sei finita dentro
in questa situazione,
te la sarai cercata!
Delusione perché ho speso
tempo, energie, risorse, lacrime
per raccontare la verità,
che è servita soltanto
ad aumentare i polverosi faldoni
che affollano gli archivi
dei Tribunali, inutilmente.
Stavo vivendo un lungo incubo,
sembrava non finire più:
mi sentivo sola e impotente,
circondata da periti e consulenti,
quelli che orbitano intorno alla Giustizia
come le iene sulle carcasse,
mie e di mio figlio piccolo.
Uno di quegli incubi -
non so se vi è mai capitato di sognare
di urlare a squarciagola,
ma in modalità muta?
Un urlo straziante,
dove però nessuno sente
e si accorge di nulla.
E io cercavo disperatamente aiuto,
ma senza mai trovarlo.
Nel momento della mia vita
in cui mi sentivo più fragile,
avevo perso tutto:
avevo perso la mia stabilità,
avevo perso la mia indipendenza,
avevo perso la mia autostima;
e soprattutto, avevo perso le mie ali.
Fino a quando mi sono resa conto
che in realtà l'aiuto lo stavo cercando
dalla parte sbagliata.
Perché nella mia vita
trascorsa sugli aeroplani,
avevo ripetuto centinaia di volte
che in caso di emergenza,
in caso di mancanza d'ossigeno in cabina,
bisognava prendere una maschera
e tirarla energicamente verso di noi,
coprendo naso e bocca,
e respirare normalmente.
E solo dopo, aiutare coloro
che hanno bisogno della nostra assistenza.
La svolta è stata proprio
in quel "energicamente verso di noi".
Perché è un'azione energica
verso me stessa,
in cui ho ritrovato quella forza nascosta,
che ha dato il via a una trasformazione.
E la prima cosa giusta che ho fatto,
mentre vivevo in affanno,
è stata quella di sviluppare una relazione
con la parte più autentica di me.
Come una radio,
dovevo risintonizzarmi
sui miei reali valori,
ascoltare i miei bisogni
e le mie ambizioni.
Ed è nella relazione con me stessa,
che ho trovato -
e non soltanto nel prendermi cura
delle mie fragilità e delle mie paure,
che ho scoperto in realtà
che proprio in quella parte
che stavo più difendendo, nel mio cuore,
in realtà c'era una via d'uscita.
E grazie a coraggio, cuore, e azione
ho ritrovato le mie ali.
Perché è proprio nel cuore
che ho scoperto una forza
che non avrei mai creduto possibile,
quella del perdono.
Intendiamoci, un perdono che non ha
nulla a che vedere con un condono,
o con un salvacondotto immeritato,
ma con un "dono" che ho fatto a me stessa
e che mi ha permesso di liberarmi
di tutti quei pesi
che non mi servivano più,
e spiegare le mie ali ed elevarmi oltre:
oltre le prepotenze, oltre le umiliazioni,
oltre alla rabbia
per l'ingiustizia subita.
Oltre.
E dopo che ho iniziato
a respirare normalmente,
ho potuto aiutare anche coloro
che avevano bisogno della mia assistenza:
i miei figli.
È incredibile che proprio dal cuore,
la parte che più credevo ferita,
io abbia ritrovato quell'energia,
il propellente che mi ha lanciata
al livello successivo della mia vita.
Facendomi arrivare veramente a traguardi
che non avrei mai pensato possibili.
È come se avessi dovuto vivere
molte vite in una
per poi imparare che in realtà
non ci sono limiti
a quello che possiamo fare
e a dove possiamo arrivare,
se non quello che ci mettiamo noi.
L'unico grande limite
di cui bisogna assolutamente disfarci
è il non sapere chi siamo veramente,
e di che cosa siamo realmente capaci.
Il credere di essere fragili,
inadeguati o sfortunati
è un grosso inganno.
E se noi, ogni giorno,
mettessimo nelle nostre vite
solo un po' di coraggio, cuore e azione,
riusciremmo veramente a arrivare ovunque,
con la consapevolezza
che siamo noi i protagonisti.
E se io, oggi,
vi regalo il mio bauletto rosso,
voi, da domani,
che cos'è che scegliete
di metterci dentro,
per spiegare le vostre, di ali?
(Applausi)